it looks like another crazy day on Wall
Street the markets open just about half
an hour ago and briefly dropped over 500
points more than two percent in the
first minute of trading but right now
the Dow Jones Industrial Average is
surging up more than 200 points that's a
lot better than yesterday when the Dow
lost more points in one day than ever
before analysts say not to worry this is
a long-overdue correction after months
of stock market gains bianna golodryga
is here with what's driving the markets
now beyond a good morning good morning
to you Gayle buckle up Monday stock
market dive rattled investors who had
been watching the markets hit record
highs and this morning many are asking
if things are looking up on Main Street
why is Wall Street seemingly so panicked
Monday's opening bell brought a
rollercoaster day on Wall Street at one
point the Dow plunged as much as 1,600
points the biggest midday loss and the
indexes history by closing it was down
1175 points enough to wipe out all gains
since the start of 2018 we're doing
fantastically the stock market hit
another note all-time high the president
regularly takes credit for the market
success the Dow has risen around 8,000
points since he took office but in
response to yesterday's sell-off the
White House said in a statement the
president's focus is on our long-term
economic fundamentals which remain
exceptionally strong the economy is
still booming some experts agree Joe
salucci is a partner at famous trading
the unemployment numbers are going lower
so the fundamentals which is what
markets are built on they're still there
but a correction was needed to kind of
get the excesses off unemployment has
fallen to a 17-year low but wages have
remained stagnant until January when
they rose by 2.9 percent
former chair of the Federal Reserve
Janet Yellen was asked on CBS Sunday
morning whether stocks were artificially
high I don't want to say too high but I
do want to say high price earnings
ratios are near the high end of their
historical range
earlier this morning overseas markets
from Britain to Japan reported
significant losses Hong Kong's main
index fell more than five percent after
yesterday's huge sell-off European
exchanges which opened later declined by
around 2% we will continue watching
watching the markets John thanks piano